l efo jeter à l'eau et pas peur de dire
n'importe quoi c'est pas grave hein
pourrait y avoir un meurtre à 20h pour
un roman noir c'est un bon début ces
objets qu'il se passe ici le roman
l'intérêt de cet atelier c'est un peu de
vous permettre d'écrire sur votre ville
sur votre environnement média roman une
fiction on va pas écrire en s'enfermant
sur nous mais où on se regarde dans une
glace c'est con
pourquoi est ce qu une écrivaine comme
vous et viendrait perdre son temps ici
avec nous j'ai pas l'impression de
perdre mon temps je suis là parce que ça
m'intéresse c'est tout
alors c'est à nous nous nationaux
d'incarner le génie français ont lieu de
pau une culture qui aujourd'hui est mise
en danger par ce métissage galopant
c'est très bien ce que ça veut dire
quand quelqu'un dit qu'ils ne
s'intéressent pas à la politique
il ne pensait plus il est ouvert son sac
assorti une kalach et avant que personne
ne puisse réagir
il a tiré la vue du sang semblait même
lui donner le courage de continuer la
chapelle dans la tête ou courroie risque
de vous choquer je trouve que le texte
d'antoine pour un premier jet est plutôt
bien écrit c'est raciste ou boule
défendue non non non non je le défends
pas j'essaie juste comprendre
[Musique]
au fond je suis persuadé que tu est
beaucoup plus intelligent que ce que tu
sais faire croire ce que vous racontez
vous intéresse vraiment pas ce que vous
faites pas
[Musique]